[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA GUPTA: TensorFlow
Lattice is useful
when you have global
trends you want your model
to respect even if your
training data is very noisy.
For example, imagine
you're training a model
to predict the time it will
take to get across town.
You know that as traffic gets
worse it should take longer.
But with noisy training examples
and a very flexible model,
the machine learning might
not pick up this basic trend.
TensorFlow Lattice
can ensure your model
learns the trends you want.
So what is a lattice?
A lattice is an
interpolated lookup table
that can approximate any
input/output relations
from your data.
You might remember
seeing a simple lattice
in the back of your
geometry textbook
to approximate
the sine function.
That was an interpolated
lookup table on just one input.
And if the exact value you're
looking for is in the table,
you can use it.
Otherwise, you find the nearest
values in the lookup table
to the one you want, and
you interpolate between them
to get the output you want.
Lattices are interpolated
lookup tables
that could be keyed
by multiple inputs
so we can approximate
multi-dimensional functions.
In fact, if you use a lattice
with enough lookup table
values, you can represent any
input/output relationship.
How does it figure out
the lookup table values?
The machine learning
trains the lookup table
values on your training
examples to minimize the loss.
SEUNGIL YOU: Lattices can help
us represent any function,
but what's great about lattices
is you can restrict them
so that they behave
sensibly rather than feeding
the noise in the data.
Suppose you're designing
a model to recommend
coffee shops to users.
You may want your system to
recommend the closest coffee
shop if all other
characteristics of each coffee
shop are exactly the same.
This type of prior knowledge
is called monotonicity.
If we have noisy
data, machine learning
doesn't always pick up
these global trends.
For example, say you train your
model on examples from Tokyo
where you can walk
to many coffee shops.
So you don't have much
training data for coffee shops
a few kilometers out.
And the data is noisy,
so the model doesn't
learn the global trend--
users prefer nearer
coffee shops.
If we try to use the
model in Texas where
you have to drive
to get coffee, we
may be surprised by the
model's unexpected behavior
for faraway coffee shops.
With lattice models,
you can easily
train a model that captures
your prior knowledge about which
subset of inputs should be
monotonically increasing
or decreasing inputs.
Under the hood, we
express monotonicity
as constraints on the
lookup table parameters.
We formulate the
machine learning task
as a constraint
optimization problem
and use TensorFlow to train it.
After the training is
done, the trained model
satisfies any monotonic
relationship you choose.
Going back to the coffee
shop recommendation example,
you can specify that
the recommendation score
decreases with the distance
but increases with the coffee
quality.
The monotonic model can behave
much more sensibly on the Texas
examples compared to a
non-monotonic flexible
function.
Capturing your prior knowledge
about monotonic relationships
really helps such
analyzation, especially when
the testing data
distribution is very
different from the
training data distribution.
JAN PFEIFER: In
TensorFlow Lattice,
we provide four
TensorFlow estimators
that are easy to use
and fit different types
and sizes of problems.
We also provide a
hyperparameters class
that allows to specify
for each feature
its monotonicity, its smoothness
regularization, and how
to handle its missing value.
Besides the usual L1
and L2 regularizers,
Lattice models also support
graph Laplacian and torsion
regularizers.
Both can help your
model generalize better
to unexplored parts
of your feature space
and can be configured
per feature
with the hyperparameters class.
TensorFlow Lattice can also
help you build customized models
by providing
calibration and lattices
as layers or as individual
TensorFlow operators.
For instance, you could extend
your already-existing model
with a lattice
layer that connects
your model and monotonic inputs
and have a mixed monotonic
model.
MAYA GUPTA: We're
excited to share
TensorFlow Lattice with
the developer community
and invite you to experiment.
You can learn more about
the technical details
from our paper, "Deep
Lattice Networks."
And we wish everyone,
happy machine learning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]